hey guys how's it going I'm Justine and
this is ROH hello we have done some what
you find videos together keep rooting in
the comments they're like why don't you
go sleep burger mania what the heck is
that
anything well if it's a food game I'm in
look at this just see 6 plus 6 plus
that's right in arrangements perfect oh
she got that oh oh I cut okay way too
much here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh what are these we'll play okay you
read the dress okay
I'll punch out of ingredients all right
it's battery installation to be done by
an adult do we have a screwdriver
double A's pretty standard I do have a
screwdriver let me go get it I got a
screwdriver oh yeah I got one everything
let me know if this is the right kind
yeah right wrong way you need a power
drill oh I got one of those too that is
slow you see you don't know I'm one to
answer maybe one two three is something
else maybe it's not speed maybe it's
like rounds okay so number one is look
IV number two is a chef's assistant and
the degree is difficult or Burgermaster
i'll start setting cheeses out hopefully
these are Tillamook that's my favorite
cheese
oh that's not real he's passed out the
end near the batteries is the starting
line just made for children a fertility
the other side is the end of the line so
the end here things aren't digital so to
play this game the ingredients can only
be handled with our tweezers where I
could only touch the dish we have to
build the ingredients and then at the
end we have to catch it if it falls are
you ready yeah we're gonna hit and then
we pick a card ready yeah here you go oh
okay oh my gosh okay I got plenty of
time this time I got a new strand what's
your strategy I'm gonna catch it after
each other I'm gonna capture like this
see it's not and then I catch it one at
a time is this cheating and why did she
do that I think you might I think I'm
cheating I don't but I don't know the
rules
I'm cheating because going faster it's
going faster we gotta get come on Jesse
you gotta get at least one burger you
get tomato speeding up I am baking Oh
can I take it okay dude here's the patty
then we got the meat then the cheese I
really thought this is gonna be easier
than it is incredibly difficult music
yeah let me catch it Dom oh there are my
shoes oh they look stressed
oh this is a double patty this is going
so fast oh no I made it backwards I
don't even think I get one fly look look
at this this is a hot mess
you won't play one more time back to
beginner mode yes okay I feel so
defeated right now I couldn't catch
anything every turn it comes right here
it just slides off did you complete any
one Oh didn't you win that round yeah
it's like I feel like a loser and this
is way more difficult you won this round
let's play another round on beginner
mode we'll see what happened okay hit
the button okay daddy oh no oh shoot I
put going wrong already
oh can you can't take it off I think the
problem is I got a stack it nicer oh
shoot oh wow all my patties fell on the
floor oh no no okay we got this we got
this okay here god this is so funny wait
and then okay I need to go faster
oh I have to lettuce no no no too many
too many one
patty in the patty patty come on eat the
cheese oh we got this this is oh this is
looking nice this is looking nice honey
look oh no no no is so difficult okay
this is a vegetarian burger we're doing
okay doing lettuce oh come on lettuce
I'll take this don't want to waste food
- made up of simple jeez no problem is
running the place it put it down Oh
Cheez Whiz you got one I hope I got
being owns right
oh I mean the best server ever we gotta
go fast gotta go fass in the patty I
really enjoy I think I got this this is
like this is like a kid's burger it just
has meat and cheese meat you should not
this real basic this is my one card I'm
gonna do this but let's catch it it's so
hard to catch him it is really hard to I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
can I can sweet here we go here we go he
let it it would start to speed up no no
oh no we got this
faster faster row faster for ten one
Windom mucho oh no no this is it chopped
[Applause]
next one it locked you like eat off the
floor lettuce tomato come here dang
tomato definitely this is definitely a
kid's meal this is double cheese
super cheesy come on I'm sorry I'm
moving ah it's alright it's alright no
don't get off though what did you I'm so
sorry I'm so I'm so sorry
do you know Oh who needs it okay last
card
okay last chance here we go win it back
I've got my technique down now got one
piece of lettuce don't mess this up bro
one piece of lettuce
we got one tomato this is it my last
card one tomato perfect
we need piece of cheese it's on there oh
no it's oh then we need it never need to
meet Patti
no you have hybird for burgers this is
the hardest part is setting it down wow
that's me as a waitress when I was a
waitress we had to assemble some stuff
like salads and soups
I loved cooking and making the food but
I was about this messy serving and
Justine I am so impressed like look you
got four I did one kids burger but at
the last second when I was placing it
down on the table it slid off let's pick
it up this was hard to see you want both
games I'm very impressed
I got a game to Justine a good thing you
dominated but I can't say you put forth
really great effort Thanks I tried well
guys thank you so much for suggesting
this cuz this was incredible I never
heard of this game before that's so fun
I really like this game it's really fun
it's way more fun than I thought it was
gonna be well thank you guys for
watching leave us some comments below
and let us know if there's anything else
you'd like to see us do and of course
you have to go check out the video that
we did on Rose Channel we uh we tasted
cats yeah bunch of different flavors of
tickets I had no idea that they had so
many different flavors so crazy we'll
check that out but with links and
description and that's it we'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]
you